this is a fascinating person to me
sandra pichai who's the ceo of alphabet
ceo of google
i admire the in a romantic
sense the madness that is
uh steve jobs and elon musk
so to me the opposite of that is who's
uh
like everybody loves him
and uh he's also a great listener so he
always brings people together and so
when
the the the energy of that person in a
room is like
the basic energy if i were to summarize
it is like i want to hear
all the voices in the room that's the
energy he brings
and uh it's almost like
he doesn't want to impose a final
decision he wants to hear all the voices
and somehow always the decision just
falls out
i don't know what to say about that
style of leadership but it's always
surprising to me how
that love brought a lot of people
together and still i mean
some of the greatest things google has
done over the past several years
uh could be attributed to that continued
innovation
bringing out the best out of people
there's of course bureaucracy which i
could criticize at the end of the day
which always happens with big companies
i would argue actually the dictatorial
style of steve jobs and elon musk helped
fight the bureaucracy which is one
criticism i would give
of being a listener and being kind is
sometimes you can't cut through the
[ __ ] as effectively
but he he's one of the only people i've
ever heard of
who everybody loves he's an
inspirational figure to millions
especially like in india he's a
celebrity
in the best kind of way is there
something you could say about that kind
of leadership where
you're never the [ __ ] you're never
the dictator
you're always the listener and the
the compassionate empathetic glue that
brings the team together
basically with love yeah that's that's
great leadership if you had to choose
for google uh
for large companies is there something
to be said about what is more effective
the dictator the uh ruling by
love or ruling by fear
first of all everything's a dichotomy
right and so
to think that all the time you're always
going to be able to
just bark orders at people and they're
always going to listen to you and you're
always going to get the best result
that would not be smart to think that
every single time
you're going to come to a 100 consensus
amongst the troops
and that decision is going to reveal
itself without you nudging it along
that would also be short-sighted and
naive so what you what a good leader
does
is they they they stay balanced and as
much as they can
they listen to what the troops have to
say they take that feedback
maybe they quietly nudge things and
and i'm sure he does that i'm sure he
does some nudging that
maybe no one even picks up on you know i
like to say the
the best forms of leadership is
leadership with minimum force required
so if i can go into a room as a leader
and not say one single thing and the
team can come to the right consensus and
move in that direction that's my
preferred method
maybe i have to give them a little bit
of a nudge a ten percent nudge in one
direction
okay that's better than me walking in
there and giving them 100 percent
dictatorial direction of exactly what i
want to have happen
now occasionally if we have an emergency
situation
people are starting to be frazzled and
they're not sure which direction to go
then sometimes as a leader you have to
walk in and say all right everyone
here's where we're going
and people get on board why because for
many years or
months or however long you've trusted
them
to come up with a plan and when you try
when you as a leader trust your team to
come up with a plan
the team starts to trust you and you get
leadership capital and as you build
leadership capital
occasionally you need to cash in some of
that leadership capital you need to
spend some of it
and maybe it is hey listen here's the
direction we're going right now
we'll debrief it later but we gotta make
a move and the team
who trusts you says roger that boss we
got it
you